mit einer geballten ladung kultur wollen
sie den herausforderungen unserer zeit
entgegen treten
wie kann das funktionieren ich glaube
einfach wir haben neue herausforderungen
auch in der schweiz oder visiert dass
die welt sich verändert die schweiz die
schaufel reden da die demografische
entwicklung die organisierung der
schweiz die globalisierung und der kulti
kultur ist die gute antwort für ein land
wie die schweiz wir haben vier sprachen
ein großer vielfalt in der in der
schweiz und gast durch die kultur können
wir machen
keiner der szene sagen es ist das
paradies der künstler hier in der
schweiz das schlaraffenland die
subventionen fließen wie milch und honig
andere nennen es eben auch das
gießkannenprinzip müsste man davon nicht
weg kommen ja genau der kleine
gießkannenprinzip und genau deswegen
biete kulturbotschaft die jetzige
verfassung steht wirklich diese idee
noch geändert wird beginnen mit einer
definition was ist die kultur was
brauchen wir in der schweiz wo sind die
prioritäten und nur nach der
refinanzierung und genau damit kann man
auch so die prioritäten finanzieren aber
die hauptpriorität ist wirklich die
teilnahme eine breite teilnahme an der
ko für alle immer im land das ist für
das team gerade mal zehn prozent der
kultur gelder kommen von ihnen oder
besser gesagt von der bundesministerin
selber wie sich das jahr
herunterzukommen
der rest der große rest kommt von
gemeinden und kanton ist die einfluss
also gar nicht so groß ich glaube wir
haben einfach die frisch und gut
koordinieren die kantone die finanzieren
fast eine milliarde die gemeinde sogar
und steckte sogar noch mehr
es gibt auch die private die sehr viel
investieren für die kultur und der bund
auch noch einige hunderte millionen und
ich habe man darf nicht das einfach
investieren ohne zu schauen was machen
die anderen es braucht eine koordination
und genau diese goldene unsere bessere
koordination wohl und wie die reifen mit
der kulturpolitik
was soll eigentlich konkret gefördert
schweizer kultur oder kultur in der
schweiz die ja oft auch von ausländern
gemacht wer beides man kann einfach
nicht ein einteiler ausschließen und uns
einfach eine gute eine gute bronze eine
gute balance finden
wir haben deswegen diese drei diese drei
prioritäten definiert erste priorität
die teilnahme zu erhöhen
an die kultur für alle sei es einfach
ein museum zu besuchen musik zu spielen
gemischter chor zu singen oder einfach
zu malen einfach in die kultur
teilzunehmen
zweite priorität ist die soziale
kohäsion zu und zu fördern weil glaube
in der schweiz
die kultur ist wirklich ein teil unserer
sozialen kohäsion mitglieder sprachen
zum zum beispiel und beträgt der
priorität und die dritte priorität das
wäre einfach die innovation für die
künstlerin ovationen traktion zur zur
unterstützung zu fördern können sie ein
konkretes beispiel nennen etwas mit den
sprachgrenzen auch passieren kann der
konkret wie man das fahren könnte ja zum
beispiel das italienische italienische
sprache nicht nur in die kino zu
unterstützen damit auch das italienische
aus china zu unterstützen im deutschen
auch hin wäre in der romandie oder das
ist auch ein teil der botschaft die die
schüleraustausche zu fördern und zu
unterstützen weil es ist damit sehr gut
möglich wie ich das land die schweiz
besser zu kennen
in ihrer kultur botschaft für die
kommenden vier jahre bekommt die vielen
branchen wir sind ja hier ein lokaler
ein ganz besonders dickes butter pro 200
millionen franken deshalb so viel geld
es gibt eine ziemlich starke
unterstützung weil es ist auch eine
aufgabe des bundes die filmförderung zu
zuzumachen
und jetzt haben wir auf feld gestellt es
lohnt sich dass diese filme auch in der
schweiz gedreht werden
genau deswegen würden wir einen neuen
instrumenten schaffen damit es ist
möglich die unter die die firma zu
unterstützen und zu unterstützen die
wirklich in der schweiz gemacht werden
es ist nicht nur filmförderung das ist
auch wirtschaftsförderung ist auch
wirtschaftlich wichtig wenn dieser film
auch hier gemacht sind die
schweizerinnen und schweizer haben ein
bisschen eine andere meinung sie gehen
sollten
in die schweizer filme sie schauen sie
sich wenig an im kino die marktanteile
sind tief im vergleich zum ausland jetzt
wo auch produziert wird setzen sie da
vielleicht auf das falsche pferd
ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht die
wieder einmal diese diese schweizer
filme sind sehr berühmt sehr bekannt es
gibt auch riesenerfolge auch noch vor
kurzem riesenerfolg kilometern holy war
ein erfolge ganz in europa noch weiter
einfach es ist auch nicht die idee mit
dem großen produktionen von malibu zu
wettbewerber oder konkurrenz zu machen
das einfach nicht möglich wir machen
aber das anders mit schweizer haft für
dich mal mal sagen und es ist auch nicht
nur für die schweiz und in der schweiz
wichtig aber auch für den ruf der
schweiz in der welt wichtig herzlichen
dank für das gespräch
danke danke